[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
antenne 2 et philips l'inventeur du
compact 10 vous présente double jeu
l'émission de thierry ardisson
[Musique]
bonjour
m
[Musique]
ce soir
je retrouvais la comédie musicale hair
plan b d'abord ya pas de remords jean
leloup après roch voisine et
larochellière encore un québécois
jamais deux sans trois django edwards le
clown de l'an 2000 non oui non il a su
mixer rap et gospel sacré cocktail plus
les uns font un tome de philippe hereng
les halles blague de laurent baffie
philippe corti l'omoplate indoor et en
invité vedette aux notaires
bonsoir mano bienvenue aux folies
bergères pour l'émission ne pas pas
maintenant tu sais ce qu'il ya ce soir
l'émission de papa maman bien euros le
vrai euros à 2 euros c'est celui qui a
le chapeau c'est celui qui a le masque
c'est celui qu'elle est petite moustache
et puis à le sergent garcia
tu es contente de voir le sergent garcia
je sais qui c'est l'invité tu sais qui
c'est l'invité ce soit il ya deux côtés
on n'a pas raté
[Musique]
dorothée bonsoir bonsoir c'est la
question que nous journalistes
on te pose en le plus souvent c'est pas
très bien habillée comme ça la question
'qui
vous êtes star des enfants et pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas d'enfant vous même
tu le connais bien cette question et tu
penses tu que nous demanderions autant
avec ça si tu étais un homme fou je
crois que oui est ce que tu crois que le
succès que tu as auprès des enfants se
consolent des méchancetés que l'on dit
sur toi ou nous parce que les
méchancetés sont toujours dures à avaler
à digérer mais cela dit quand quand on
parle avec les enfants qu'il vous donne
des critiques plus ou moins gentil
agressive on sait qu'elles sont vraies
donc on les accepte plus facilement
alors que celle des adultes on sait pas
trop d'où elles viennent tuer bourg ou
contre les ficelles pour quand c'est
bien nommé mais quoique non contre et as
tu déjà à gifler un enfant jamais mais
si tu continues
peut-être que je vais pour toi qu'est-ce
qu'il est plus violent pour un enfant
depuis gerland pour un enfant je crois
que c'est ne pas avoir d' amour d'un
mort de ses parents de ses frères et
soeurs de ses copains et les parents
sont toujours battus déjà reçu une
lettre de gens désespérés qui voulait te
confier leurs enfants des lettres non
mais j'avoue qu'un jour lors d'une
dédicace ya une jeune fille qui est
arrivé en disant j'ai mon bébé dans les
bras les uns les bras et me dit je peux
faire une photo bien sûr je prends la
pitchoune et will photographes ou la
photo et la main on partait elle me le
confiait donc on a récupéré le larron du
son enfant d un coup d excuse moi mais
tu es la maman c'est ton enfant tout en
occupe et ses serveuses normal mais j'ai
eu très très peur
imaginons on sait jamais tu est nommé
ministre de l'éducation nationale non
d'accord imaginons tu est nommé ministre
de l'éducation nationale qu'est-ce que
tu ferais mais je me dis ministre
suivaient un enfant tu emmènerait ou
pour le distraire
à ton émission ou pour le punir
peut-être à l'émission d'ardisson parce
que elle se définit
on se croirait à bercy cet automne tout
comme marc doré était bon soir on
voulait t'inviter parce que tu es bon tu
es très connu mais très peu connu on
sait peu de chose de toi
donc on va discuter pendant pendant une
heure tu veux pas parler de toi pourquoi
pas ce que tu veux pas sortir de ton
rôle ou pas ce cas rien à savoir ce que
je réponds aux questions que l'on me
pose c'est aux vierges analyser toutes à
leurs noms mais enfin bon ouais un peu
dur à l'impôt dit rien une cigarette non
merci j'ai filmé par la télévision
il arrête tu fumes combien par jour
entre deux cigarettes rien à ton vrai
nom c'est frédéric comment c'est très
dur à dire oui c'est pour ça que je
l'oublié hd hbo hd
je comprends que tu es changé c'est dur
à dire mais dur à écrire aussi qu'est ce
que tu as trouvé dorothée voilà ça c'est
fait il ya un petit moment de ça il
fallait un prénom qui se passe a dit
rick hannah prénom androgyne dont les
l'époque on m'a dit il faut que tu es un
prénom féminin alors allez trouver un
prénom quand on a vécu quelques années
avec alors on a commencé à chercher les
grecs n joubert bien sûr proserpine
cunégonde à retenir c'est vrai alors
c'est simple
catherine j'ai des copines zapper
catherine paulette c'était beau paf à
marans à l'époque et dorothée venu comme
ça et je ne sais pas pourquoi tu te
rappelles encore frigate personne même
pas ta mère non même que les rumeurs ça
peut être de revient était vieille
copine que je revends une photo en
écartant j'ai remarqué que tu disais ton
âge
oui 39 ans en corée ou pas encore c'est
ce que seront les 3 48-3 car cette jeune
pâte dure formage non je m'écoute je
trouve que ces jeunes ou vieux 38 ans
veut rien dire
là je sais vraiment ce qu'on aura test
le ter sur quatre entités bon dans la
tête tu as quel âge quatre ans et demi
en corse
je fais des efforts tu mesure combien 1
est 62 c'est pas beaucoup
et toi 80 à peu près donc ça mais c'est
mieux que l'homme soit plus grand que le
fils et tu pèses combien 45 1
j'éclate un peu non non ça va
dans les cheveux noirs au départ chacun
très cliché d'un très clair et tu les as
décolorés pourquoi c'est ça la met
d'accord c'est vrai que tu as perdu 10
kilos quand tu es rentré à la télé exact
donc c'est un bon secret a donné aux
femmes avant les départs en vacances et
de faire de la télé finalement non c'est
un hasard c'est très bien comme ça parce
qu'avant je mangeais que des sucreries
est ce que tu es prête pour faire une
interview première fois première baffe
je n'ai jamais été giflé par mes parents
sans en parler copine sa charge mais par
les hommes
sympa non un bon jamais à le premier qui
essaye on va faire les pourtours premier
noël premier noël
oui j'avais une jaunisse je me souviens
j'avais une très belle robe de chambre
jaune assorties justement amazonie ses
tout premiers objets fétiches pour ce
dont j'avais arracher les oreilles et
les yeux tu vas garder
j'ai toujours eu peur avec non c'est pas
avec lui et que tu dois premier péché
premier péché qu'est-ce que j'ai pris ça
comme des titres l'ag de trop d'enfer tu
sais tiens moi mon premier match et si
je peux pas le raconter à la tv on va
dire mais entre nous dans l'été deux
petits copains comme ça mais tu es jeune
tu avec l âge
cet âge a déjà
c'est à ce genre de choses là je joue à
quoi qu'un peu de petit j'étais chef de
bande
tu joues et tu préférais jouer quand il
était petit à cache-cache au docteur à
cache cache jamais joué tellement
d'autres peuvent non même si j'ai chanté
docteur j'étais bien sûr multiway
première boum
j'avais 19 ans et demi j'aime rester dix
minutes pas plus nous plaît pas c'est
quoi qui ne plaisait pas les filles et
les garçons soient serrés les uns contre
les autres les requêtes away j'ai fait
le service militaire dont vous savez
savoir plus à sa première idole c'était
kit dorothée à toi c'était fred astaire
ginger rogers et surtout de rêveurs
premier flirt ou t'en souviens eux
c'était qui en angleterre où il était
grand très grand très très grand que
s'ils s'étaient passés exactement qui
ressurgissent tout genre c'était gentil
tout ça quand il veut être un petit peu
plus sur la première cuite
certainement après un spectacle après
jeu de la vérité de chantal goya
sympa ce premier amour bon je fais pas
tu veux que je te parle d'amour quand
même des muscles et quelques bars pour
monsieur dassier crois que j'ai un bon
contact avec la dame manavit sont
musclés fais gaffe ils sont cinq sont
grands là aussi il y en a c'est fait
mais s'accroît premier amour alors
hausse était très gentil très très très
romantique l'aéronautique bon première
expérience sexuelle
ça s'est très bien passé merci c'est
vers quel âge à cet art là aussi
l'inventaire de battre
je comptabilise le fait gaffe c'est un
marquage au j'avais 18 ans quand même
oui et alors c'était très beau faire
garder un bon souvenir
tu la revue à il s'est cassé le même
premier joint te fumer j'avais jamais
fumé de mais non là je crois pas écoute
si tu as dit qu'on allait être sincère
mais l'idée bon d'accord premier succès
côté télé côté 10 côté premier succès de
tête vit la première fois où tu t'es dit
tiens ça y est ça marche
y'a pas d'hier non il n'a pas d'hier n'a
rien rien ne prendre que deux claques
dans la gueule
j'ai arrêté la premier c'est que c'est
je crois que c'est où la menteuse je
crois ou là vraiment je quand dans la
dans la rue les gens m'ont dit à l'ats
venteuse est amoureuse c'est quand les
gens dans la rue te parler tu l'écoutés
bref a bien marché à new york
premiers millions d'anciens francs mais
pas trop quand on n'y a pas très
longtemps
il est dit rien j'ai battu là bas il a
peur de toile je suis fortement à
trancher c'est la première fois que je
mets quelqu'un de torcher mais aussi
vite un bravo premier million de
nouveaux faux suffit pas à temps en
hautement j'en sais rien si j'ai sur mon
compte je sais pas ce que tu me dis
attention des thons rouges bomba
d'accord attention tout passe dans la
drogue
le premier geste que tu fais le matin je
râle je croyais un tiens c'est une
question piège alors qu'est ce que le
second se découvrir les gestes que tu
fais le matin
c'est pas allumer la tv non cette
deuxième c'est comme mtv chez toi une
dans chaque pièce
ça fait combien tu sais qu'on est le 21
mars et le 1er kouassi le 21 mars dans
l'étreinte au premier jour du printemps
eh oui si vous regardez un sujet sur le
prendre car toi c'est très fleur bleue
cette émission la vénérable république
de genève est connu surtout pour son jet
d'eau son luxe sa vieille ville et ses
traditions
ce que l'on sait moins c'est qu'un haut
fonctionnaire du conseil d'état de
genève
l'équivalent chez nous du secrétaire
général de l'elysée est chargé parmi les
tâches de gestion administrative qui lui
incombe de gaieté chaque année l'arrivée
du printemps
rôle qu'il remplit d'une façon bien
particulière avec l'aide d'un marronnier
officiel cette tradition remonte au
xviiie siècle
alors chaque année dès que l'atmosphère
se réchauffe un petit peu ça peut
commencer en janvier ça peut être plus
tard suivant la saison suivant la
température je me rends sur cette
promenade j'observe les marronniers et à
un moment donné j'aperçois que le
bourgeon commence à s'entrouvrir qu'il
ya ce qu'on appelle techniquement labour
qui sort quand je surveille mon beaujon
les bourgeons il a plusieurs et 1re
particulier se distinguent
jusqu'au moment où selon le geste
traditionnel le bourgeon s'ouvre alors
j'aperçois concrètement la première fois
et c'est ce que j'annonce à ce moment là
à la presse j'annonce l'arrivée de la
première feuille et du même coup le
printemps au départ le sautier était le
chef des gays la fonction était
essentiellement militaire et par la
suite notamment aussi de passer elle
sait si j'ose dire intellectualiser et
le sautier devenu petit à petit le
secrétaire permanent du grand conseil
c'est à dire du parlement genevois au
fond c'est une façon très poétique
d'annoncer la venue du printemps qui
tranche sur les ordinateurs qui ausculte
la métérologie de notre planète
je crois que c'est quelque chose qui est
très rousseauiste dans son origine sa
révèle aussi combien la suisse est
encore très prisonnière de ses
traditions et donc qu'elle est un petit
peu encore enfermés
dans ces montagnes peut protéger et qu
elle se crispe un peu sur ses traditions
et ça c'est le côté très passéiste de la
suisse qu'on peut lui reprocher je mets
attends et qu'annoncé par un marronnier
officielle s de l'info est de l'intox
d'heurter à l'oreille
alors maintenant mesdames messieurs
pendant que zorro et garcia
réfléchissent ici qu'est ce qu'on écoute
corti jerry est ce que tu le sens ce
soir le soleil de bonnes vibrations
est ce que vous le sentez vos cils à 200
g
j'habite
[ __ ]
et
oh
[Musique]
m
après
à
hu
[Musique]
non
les mauvais
eh oui
baa
web
[Musique]
m
tha
[Musique]
m
or est annoncée par un marronnier
officiel c'est de l'info c'est de
l'intox attend à vison c'est de l'info
c'est l'info ouais pourquoi parce que
c'est complètement fou hein ça me plaît
bien te plait bien peu sur bien moi
j'essaie sacre estimé rony en fleurs
comme ça 21 mars à juin et toi garcia ah
ouais je pense que c'est de l'info c'est
parce que celui-ci 6,6 fois dorothée sur
m'a dit que c'était de l'intox
oui on écoute l'expert philippe bière
alors fini avant de vous donner la
réponse à cette question ô combien
philosophique et rousseauiste je me
permettrai de nous féliciter
mutuellement quelques instants vous
savez que depuis la semaine dernière en
tapant 36,15 coda 2 vous pouvez obtenir
dès la fin de l'émission le pourcentage
exact de gens ayant répondu info et le
pourcentage de gens ayant répandu intox
bravo pour vous la semaine dernière le
godemiché olympique vous n'avez été que
44% à vous faire piéger
et bravo pour nous samedi dernier vous
avez été 57% à vous faire piéger par le
licenciement pour cause d'anomie trop
débordante
un point partout maintenant la réponse
pour le marronnier officiel dorothée il
fallait regarder le sujet puisque
c'était de l'info
alors ma fille le score est vite on a
déjà perdu deux points ça fait un
partout
ouais d'accord bois
shigure mais c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave non pas important je me trompe à
chaque fois de très bon ben on va voir
alors comme tu es responsable de la
jeunesse
sur la chaîne de télévision la plus
regardée de france j'ai de faire une
interview moralité pour savoir à qui
nous confions nos enfants d'accord alors
première question as tu déjà piqué quand
j'étais petit dans le porte-monnaie de
ta maman wee aa
est ce que tu as déjà fouiller dans les
poches de la personne avec qui tu vivais
j'ai souvent failli j'aime et non je
suis allé jusqu'au bout
c'était bien même dans la banlieue et tu
déjà sortie avec la copine d'un copain
et kato pyrgos a dû m'arriver ouais
ouais on ne citera l'ordre du mérite
jean paul une action de bravoure que
t'as pas commis cet été là mais c'est
pas toi qui a fait le geste qui a sauvé
dit que c'est pas moi c'était vraiment
comme ça mais je suis désolé couteau
pour d'autres questions mais je sais pas
non mais non je sais que je te fais une
interview moralité n'arrête pas de me
faire des réponses moral larry tu
trouves jeu ça va venir
tu trouves un nourrisson abandonné sur
un bailleur ce cauchemar erreur tu vois
j'ai appelé la foule à se trouver un
nouveau mode fait des cauchemars
c'est pas salé des abandonnés qu'est ce
que t'en fais quand je dis non c'est toi
ou leur finale et si tu fais pas je
je préfère que ce soit moi mes
responsabilités
touya peut pas dire ça à la télé parce
que les gens vont les déposer des mici
cote des fois tu joue aux cartes chez
toi avec les maquilleuses des gens qui
croient avec toi tu triches oui tu
trouves ça moral de tricher avec des
gens qui sont tes employés
oui ce qu'on triche elle aussi elle
triche baffie a fait un test de moralité
dans la balance et des gentils namik oui
tu entends tu veux regarder ah oui bien
sûr il ya laurent baffie le petit chef
[Musique]
discret c'est pour nous un malade il ya
des fraises
il serait allé si c'est pour vous dire
comment mr vengeance et pardon sortie je
les applique à l'étalagé juge faut pas
le pas ce qu'on met sa patte bien vous
voulez enfin dupont donnez moi la pièce
kovalev d'être complice dans aussi un
petit larcin s'est pas non aux produits
non les idées de mon avis est simplement
mais discret merci madame enfin la pièce
là c'est un froid vous me donnez les à
mélanger qu'on me dit prenez les non non
les y aller j'y vais pas non alors venez
mois a redonné mois apprend alors c'est
pas moi moi c'est du vol
c'est pas moi ben moi je suis
délinquants ya bataille sur ce coup là
mais non je vais prendre un point alors
un front les fraser qui est d'accord
magistrats et un hacker a quand même
fougue les uns bonne pour vous mettre
sympathique il m a pâti ça fait plaisir
ça fait plaisir
comment je le prends très bien beau
aussi ya aucun problème à la 6ème peuple
vous les payez pas les fraises et non
mais pas du tout alors parti en courant
c'est du vol paris alger pas bougé pas
bougé pas bougé pas comme ça ça comme ça
je peux vous en dire plus merci madame
le partageront par tâche énorme appétit
à deux on la paie 10 à 2
je m'inquiète oui je me trouve mais
c'est pour le volet non non non je ne
voulais pas volé mes marques et je ne
veux pas volé ah bon c'est empêcher ce
n'est pas de chichis c'est un péché oui
c'est empêcher de voler on peut dire ce
soir on doit pas mourir pendant mais on
peut même pas tiqué enfin il faut pas
prendre ça aux enfants à bord et déjà
cet âge là ça va tuer même à papa non
non non et les parents que vous êtes
dans son pays pendant leurs envies
le défi
également la morale de la faire donc
c'est que les magistrates prennent les
trucs volée et les portugais les
immigrés portugais donc finalement donne
des leçons de morale et les prennent pas
donc ça remet en cause beaucoup de
théories qui circulent en ce moment j'ai
prié nadia parce que tu as dit la morale
donc mais c'est ça la morale fallait le
dire quand même 10 - dorothée témoin pas
rencontré un titre comme ma fille
pourquoi on applaudit laurent baffie
alors on va parler un petit peu de ta
carrière à travers les noms qui l'ont
marqué et bien entendu le premier c'est
françois truffaut qui l'a connu comment
j'étais à l'époque speakerine way et
judas ou dans ma dans la petite cabine
et puis un jour le téléphone sonne et à
chaque fournée 20 gars qui circulait en
cabine speakerine s'évade hinse et c est
tout un accord à l'eau en fin de compte
c'était les différences de programme ou
l'ecopack téléphoner et j'entends à
l'eau frein truffaut l'appareil mais oui
bien sûr moi je suis catherine deneuve
et je raccroche le téléphone rouge sonne
enfin bref c'était vraiment mais c'est
truffaut qui m'appelait parce qu'il
travaillait en regardant la télévision
et il m'avait vu et voulait tourner avec
moi ça fait faire l'amour en fuite
d'études ihs quitté a choisi pour ton
côté androgyne
c'est ce que m'avait dit à l'époque
qu'est ce que tu as à vendredi je sais
pas peut-être qu'elle et j'avais j'ai un
caractère qui est quand même pour les
films ou de temps en temps ouais pas en
temps mais quand je veux
tamino robe ouais c'est pas la remonter
un tout petit peu mieux mais un panda
coeur tu fais un autre film après avec
robert enrico qui s'appelait pile ou
face
eh bien voyez toutes nues quand même
jusque là rue lui envoyer les seins
ouais quoi en fin de vie neige non les
voisins on les voyait moi j'ai pas de
l'ubs dont je mens pas connard il était
petit non je peux te dire un truc moi
j'ai revu une photo en étudiant le
dossier davantage sa visité petit joly
ils sont superbes apparemment après
truffaut apprennent rico 3e nom de ta
carrière et non des moindres jacqueline
joubert heldt a rencontré tu jouais dans
une troupe de théâtre amateur 1
une pièce de musset eux la caprice et
alors ça se passait comme c'était un
concours de théâtre de jeanne elle
faisait partie du jury
et puis bon il m'a remarqué et a fait
les mercredis de la jeune et j'ai passé
des auditions après quand même
et voilà c'est parti comme ça alors un
an plus tard tu as été virés pourquoi on
te dit que finalement n'était pas fait
pour présenter 2 émissions enfantines
c'est ce qu'on a dit bizarre pam qui t'a
dit ça mais balance c'était pas la main
en fait plus on sait qu'un responsable
de l'epa peut-être qu'ils avaient raison
bah non la preuve c'est yann victor
lélio d'hector qui était déjà alors
chacune jouer un rôle qui n'est pas ça
la preuve que non c'est pas vrai quand
elle a eu la responsable qui était bien
sur antenne 2
vient on à paris à jouer on le fait tous
les deux entre les doutes à une
traversée du désert terrible tu as fait
des petits boulots tu as été doublure
lumière jusque là ça va ça va tu as été
animatrice dans les supermarchés donc
augmentation beaucoup moins passionnant
tu comprends ce le souffle daniel
gilbert aujourd'hui et tu as été
recensés je crois pas si secrétaire dans
une entreprise de robinetterie et
pourquoi d'où son dégoût pour les hommes
explique ce bon c'était des gens qui a
besoin d'une secrétaire débutante
pas cher payé ouais j'avais pris entre
temps des courses dactylographie quand
on sait pas cependant si vous avez plus
jamais faire la paix était fini donc est
ce qu'on fait on prend des contacts kg
et puis j'étais engagé mais je crois
qu'il s'assure toujours parmi les
pauvres de me faire 15 ans a way le pire
moment à cette époque c'était quoi
durant cette traversée du désert
produits métro tous les matins à 7
heures après et est revenue à des
horaires fixes
après tu es revenue à la télé donc
jacqueline joubert lui a demandé de
revenir et en 87 donc tu quittes les
services publics
tu te brouille avec jacqueline joubert
tu disais que tu étais deuxième maman
mais comme tu as vraiment été d'accord
pour que tu partes maintenant ce n'est
pas un problème quoi c'est pas ça c'est
que jacqueline a toujours dit qu'il
fallait
changer et grandir dans la vie et quand
il a fallu donc changé et choisir et
puis grandir en changeant et de chênes
et de style démission et l'a pas suivie
de jeu quand elle la vraie maman l'a
fait mais qui est très méchante avec
fois jacqueline joubert massy el azizia
enfin tu es parti de travailler avec les
gens avec qui tu travailles maintenant
elle a dit elle et par elle s'est vendu
un gangster c'est pas très gentil quand
même non si la croyait capable de dire
ça jacqueline joubert
non mais je crois que c'est elle sur le
moment en plus quand le temps à faire
son oeuvre
ça passera vite à pardonner tu crois
j'espère toi tu lui a pardonné d'avoir
dit ça mais jamais le gang c'est en
question c'est ton producteur actuel
c'est jean luc azoulay tu l'a connue
comment je les connais comment c'est lui
qui m'a contacté parce qu'il avait une
hépatite virale et alors tu sait soigner
les hépatites vers l'arctique une
hépatite virale
j'ai souffert autant pour moi il n'est
pas tu te vire à la et donc de prendre
les bus mais sur la gueule tu vois juste
les tortues ninja plus le sens devrait
comprendre
non mais et qui m'a dit la télévision
qui voit là tu actionnaires de sa
société
pas du tout tu regrettes pas de palais
brongniart surtout pas pourquoi femme
d'affaires prenait temps tu viennes
beaucoup d'argent montagnat sais de quoi
tu dis toujours que tu sais pas vous
mais bien sûr rien au monde et je veux
rentrer à voir je peux pas croire qu'à
39 ans sache pas qu'en vue en gagnant
enfin je ne sais pas combien je gagne je
sais pas combien je dépense
maintenant je veux bien le croire mais
non je suis pas la menteuse arrête
personne ne croit jamais jean ça rien
que tu saches pas comment tu dépenses je
veux bien le croire petit singe pas
quand mais je vous promets que nous donc
tu gères pas ton argent public
mais comment tu fais quand tu veux de
l'argent tu as besoin d'argent parce
qu'avec 5
tu me à ses idées alors jean luc azoulay
et non seulement ton producteur mais en
plus quand tu pars en vacances avait
triste un ami et en plus il écrit les
paroles de tes chansons eux c'est
beaucoup quand maintenant c'est lui
l'homme de ta vie en fait mais c'est en
tentant sous-entendu non non non il a
rien de l'éclat 20 savoir qui c'est non
pas qu'on peut savoir à la fin de
l'émission est l'homme de la vidéo nous
claque le beignet une chance bon
j'aurais pu faire du cinéma
je fais de la télé mais dans l'univers
dans lequel tu vis est ce que finalement
avec tous ces dessins animés gaza est-ce
que tu aurais pas aimé être cosmonautes
finalement non merde c'est pourquoi
parce que j'avais un enchaînement avec
le cosmonaute
j'aurais bien aimé peut-être sympa cette
mostra terrestre oui voilà l on regarde
alors à corps m'a sauvé mon enchaînement
merci rien cela devenait obsédant coincé
dans sa verte belgique
il ne pensait plus qu'à cela ses proches
ne pouvait rien pour lui
ça s'est fait petit à petit croix oui
mais on peut rien faire 1 et l'a fait ça
dans sa tête et et puis le miracle s'est
produit l'espace allait être à lui la
nasa l'a appelé il allait faire partie
des 200 astronautes dans le monde il
serait levé bien bien accroché à rouen
ça devient une vocation un définition
donc
on met tout en oeuvre pour y arriver
vous n'avez pas toujours hélas lui a
réussi
voici dirk frimout tu ce drôle de savon
ne passera pas inaperçu dans la famille
de l'espace il est docteur en physique
il a 50 ans le bon âge paraît-il il sera
le premier astronaute belge et il en est
ravi
j'apprécie beaucoup votre intérêt dans
cette mission qui est important pour la
belgique sur le plan humain parce que je
suis le premier baez qui allocation de
voler dans l'espace n'a pas l'air
d'avoir 50 ans vous voyez en tout cas
quand vous le sentez pression d'eau
apprécié à quelqu'un plus jeunes c'est
un grand boy scout mais au sens noble du
terme
aujourd'hui dirk freymuth s'entraîne à
houston il s'envolera le 23 mars
prochain à bord de la navette américaine
atlantis but de sa mission étudier les
influences du soleil sur l'atmosphère et
les climats du crime entend aussi
profiter de l'occasion pour se livrer à
sa passion communiquer avec les
radioamateurs j'espère qu'on pourra
apporter des données très intéressant
pour eux à bientôt
à bientôt dans l'espace et ce n'est que
justice pour la belgique car
souvenez-vous 20 ans varane strong les
premiers voyageurs dans l'espace était
belge et la ressemblance de l'un d'eux
avec dirk est saperlipopette étonnante
ab
un beige dans l'espace mais là messieurs
s de l'info est de l'intox d'heurter à
l'oreille
alors maintenant mesdames messieurs
pendant quelques euros sa base hors eau
et le sergent garcia sava garcia merci
réfléchissent qu'est ce qu'on écoute
corti sorti ses marques ou sid
ouais c'est ça c'est vrai je lui ai dit
qu'elle allait voir le loup elle a mal
pris jean de luz
attention je vais vous faire une chanson
le juger en des temps les yeux de mon
image je suis soucieux en 1990 c'est
l'heure des communications
la réaction
[Musique]
ça va glisser
c'est toi
c'est un super mec
qui se sert
je suis
c'est la conscientisation
[Musique]
m
aux soldats américains qui sont la base
française
ce moment
de megève
88 des voix
[Musique]
espace j'aurais peut être un belge dans
l'espace s de l'info est de l'intox
c'est à toi de jouer
il croit que les belges pourquoi pas
dans l'espace à bord je crois que c'est
de l'info tu penses qu'à un belge qui
peut aller dans les styles sont souvent
dans la rue dont plus jeune âge à voir
mais 3 au bout on va redescendre sur
terre je dirais que c'est de l'intox
bien que celle là ça sera de la butte et
ouais c'est le togo a dit que c'était de
l'info au pourquoi tu sais tu sais
quelque chose
je crois que je voudrais tu crois que
c'est vraiment on écoute l'expert
philippe guérin bravo dorothée bravo
c'était de l'info à bravo dorothée
tu es un commentaire mon fils ou et oui
c'était de l'info et comment aurait-il
pu en être autrement arrêtons ces
blagues idiotes sur les belges qui ne
nous ont pas attendus pour inventer les
frites
annie cordy est un teint à propos de
tintin les belges ne se sont pas
contentés que de l'inventer ils ont
aussi inventé les éditions casterman des
éditions qui veille jalousement sur les
intérêts de tintin par exemple chez ces
gens là pour montrer la couverture d'un
album de tintin il faut payer 1000
francs français pas belge dit madame
dorothée pour montrer la couverture de
votre journal faut payer combien ils
sont ravis comme tu veux il peut la
vendre et en prévoit elle est pas belle
alors ben si le score 2-1 pour garcia
alors dorothée on arrive à un dur moment
maintenant passer les fameuses questions
cons à lola ohlala alors ce commence
simplement tu es jarretelles ou collante
ses collants bon d'accord t'es soutien
gorge ou seins nus
bon ok j'ai pas vraiment toujours trouvé
à ma taille c'était à dire que la tessin
nuit tu veux dire
torse nu est ce que tu es slip ou
caleçon qu'elle souhaite
ah ouais j'avoue ça dès qu'elle ferait
tout va mal oui je décale sont sous
cette robe non pas qu'elles sont nées
des grands achats des grands machins eux
est-ce que tu préfèrerais mourir les
dentelles soit machin non non pas tu
comprends tu dis que tu arrives pas tu
marier mais tu comprends si tu si tu dis
je me dis jamais tu préfèrerais mourir
rayon laser bombe à neutrons ou gaz
inodore au laser ça fait plus spectacle
laser c'est bien malgache gaz inodore
t'avais pas français
tu pouvais continuer à tendre nos
invités de ce coup ci on sait bien
changer tout ça c'est bien continuez
monsieur
paf alors imagine imagine que tu sois
coincés dans un ascenseur veut déjà
imagine que tu sois confessé dans un
ascenseur qui préférait être coincé avec
qui catherine lara jma repas muriel
robin ou marie paule belle
non non je ne sais pas choisissant une
un ascenseur c'est pas une navette
spatiale qui par mail rodin dans ses
rangs des histoires ah ouais muriel
robin avec toi dans un ascenseur pendant
qu'en même temps tu tiendrait déboires
ces ascenseurs qui risque de tenir alors
ton julie arrive par imagine c'est une
supposition tout ça c'est des questions
fort suppositions suppositions ton
julien arrives pas tu lui demande
comment elle s'appelle premières
suppositions deuxième suppositions tu
lui fais un truc spécial pour qu'ils y
arrivent troisièmes suppositions tu te
casses en claquant la porte
à demain tu te casses en claquant la
poche rapport dont j'ai gardé du temps
va bien on verra demain la question
suivante j'aimerais bien être la pause
et pas ici peut pas de vent pas devant
tout le monde peut wallonie voilà à pas
loin
d'accord c'est bien ok
oui tu prends de rezé si tu devais
partir sur une sur une île déserte
tu choisirais qui entre de chavannes de
caunes frédéric mitterrand au moins dû
provoquer je suis obligé de dire toi
non franchement du franchement toi on va
pas être triste
c'est vrai tu prends mal moi euh c'est
pas tirer une semaine sur l'île déserte
avec moi mais je dois faire c'est pas
loin
une bise sur les joueurs promis oui
quand même
on y retourne c'est tout seul on y va
mais je te dirai quand je parle pas ça
je crois que c'est bon bon moi je crois
que c'est bon pour moi quinze jours
j'essaie de rouler une pelle ça n'a pas
marché mais j'ai une ouverture c'est
vous bon on va parler business un peu ma
petite dorothée aux caisses qui a
d'autres l'amour l'argent
1 alors t'as combien d'heures sur tf1
par semaine nous inquiète
une vingtaine a tu le sais ça parfois
sais pas combien tu gagnes mais tu sais
quand même mais avec jean luc azoulay
votre site est quand même à peu près 70
% des émissions des moins de 12 ans pas
mal quand même
tu as vendu combien de l'album tu sais à
peu près 12 millions ah bon ouais tu
serais pas le premier tu sais combien tu
as d'acheteurs pour dorothée magazine
tous puis 150 milles ouais je sais qu on
m a fait entrer à bercy attend 130
milles 462 mais le temps des voiries pas
mal quand même non et les chiffres très
bien dire pour moi je passais pas c'est
intéressant d'avoir une salle pleine
ouais enfin les chiffres intéressants
parce que tu toucherait 1 franc par
entrer cette fois déjà 170 millions je
suis pas ta vidéo est triple platine
bien tu vois sympa ça il faut que tu
viennes ici pour savoir attendre bien
plus souvent devraient travailler
ensemble alors sans compter la chine
parce que skipper exceptionnel c'est
qu'il est devenu star en chine si c'est
pas de la rigolade quand même donc allé
en chine au départ c'était comme ça
juste pour faire un petit
des spectacles dans une petite salle à
shanghai et puis tu es retourné je crois
que la troisième fois c'est la troisième
année me via les quatre fois j'aimerais
et c'était un grand coup de foudre du
thabor grande histoire d'amour
pourquoi est-ce que tu as le chinois
sont fascinés par les gens qui ont le
nez un peu comme ça on trouve et régalé
le stadium
quoi que je peux y avait mon goal i
aussi tu as fait un tabac dit mathieu a
quoi comme habile succès c'est moi j'ai
une théorie sur toi un maintien c'est
que ta voix et mais une fréquence
spéciale à laquelle les enfants sont
particulièrement réceptifs mais en chine
sur pas des enfants qui viennent sont
des adultes gkp éviter le but en chine
mais ça c'est déjà ça y est mort tu dis
que tu n'as pas autant d'argent qu'on
croit mais est ce que tu sais combien on
imagine avec l'emploi du temps que tu as
tous les acteurs d'un robot commander
c'est quoi le secret de ta forme j'ai dû
lui être un robot bionique
pas du tout je croyais pas si tant que
ça ah bon tu dis ça pour ton image parce
que c'est vrai que je crois qu'à un
moment tu sais que tu travailles est
vachement tué un jour tu t'es dit quand
même pour moi l'image que j'arrête de
dire que je travaille tout le temps que
je travaille beaucoup quand même travail
beaucoup quand ils ne font mais quand
j'ai pas besoin je travaille bien
séparées ce trèfle m mais cette tendance
à la paresse tu as le temps de vérifier
quand quand il travaille tout le temps
on touchera pas tout le temps du
week-end je travailles pas tu fais quoi
quand tu fais rien
rien vraiment rien à ce que j'ai lu dans
un journal tu disais que tu fais là
réussi c'est un truc pour la wii je sais
c'est vrai ouais c'est pas dur tu me
trouveras machine tpu sur un bouton a
même pas fait pour ça elle est blanchi
l'argent
oui ça c'est donc ça c'est pas pour les
journalistes ici
non ça va j'aime bien faire rentrer
aussi ah bon mais je veux tu es bien
comme pépé on arrive une fois tous les
we quand même c'est bien joué dommage
fatma les avis trois pièces la lessive
la vaisselle le meilleur moment
finalement ton meilleur moment c'est pas
quand tu te retrouves chez toi avec ton
chien s'est pas d'abord il s'appelle
jean bleu non il s'appelle roxana
s'accroît que 501
c'est un petit garçon ça me suis sentie
monsieur et c'est pas le meilleur moment
ça quand tu es tout seul chez lui j'ai
pas un meilleur moment j'ai plein de
menton tout temps tu sais qu'il ya des
psychologues pour chiens maintenant oui
bon d'accord on regarde on chien machine
zidane voyez ici consulte régulièrement
depuis deux ou trois mois
un psychiatre pour chiens pourquoi
j'amenais machine dit nash et psychiatre
c'est que elle pense qu'elle ne plaît
plus elle pense que que qu'elle est trop
grosse et c'est vrai qu'elle est un
petit peu un petit peu en baisse donc
elle fait un vrai complexe aujourd'hui
de plus en plus de chiens a stressé par
la vie des grandes villes ont besoin
d'un psy à l'heure où le syndicalisme
français connaît un déficit 2010 dans
une désaffection certaine s'inscrivant
dans une ville résolument optimiste le
premier syndicat des comportementaliste
animalier s'apprête à fêter ses trois
ans d'activité syndicale a été fondée en
1989 sous l'initiative d'un groupe de
psychologues de vétérinaires éthologue
et de comportementaliste alors ce
syndicat a pour objectif il a plusieurs
objectifs en fait c'est de regrouper ces
professionnels de la psychologie pour
créer un groupe de travail et de
recherche dans les domaines de la
psychothérapie animal quatre coins
définissent la stratégie du bureau
directeur fédération des professionnels
de la psychologie animale édition de
plaquettes d'information organisation de
séminaires de recherche création d'un
dispensaire pour animaux en difficulté
psychologique
les cadres du syndicat se recrutent
surtout chez les psychologues et les
psychiatres départ j'ai une formation
universitaire et j'ai un dea de
psychologie militer pour moi c'est
d'abord donner de l'information aux gens
sur ce métier qui est plus ou moins
connus et puis c'est aussi réunir des
professionnels
qu'ils viennent de différents domaines
les militants sont aussi des
propriétaires de chiens ayant eu à faire
pratiquer une psychothérapie à leur
animal et qui veulent en savoir plus
long ce qui est intéressant avec avec
ces séances c'est que nous mêmes on
apprend beaucoup de choses puisqu'on est
toujours là
on apprend beaucoup de choses sur sur le
chien général
c'est vrai qu'au départ le chien est un
peu
un jouet pour tout le monde un compagnon
mais ça s'arrête là
et en fait il a des réactions on peut
dire humaine la névrose animal est un
concept désormais couramment admis reste
à faire connaître l'existence et la
nécessité du syndicat il ya un syndicat
c'est très bien mais de façon mon chien
tourner le dos maintenant la psychiatrie
et je crois que je vais sur nous de
remplacer le premier syndicat français
six colloques pour chien s de l'info est
de l'intox
dorothée à l'oreille des deux je peux me
laver du tout alors maintenant mesdames
messieurs pendant que zorro et garcia
réfléchissent ici pendant que vous
réfléchissez chez vous qu'est ce qu'on
écoute corti
[Applaudissements]
avant le décollage
nous vous prions de relever vos
tablettes ainsi que vous ciel et
d'attacher leur ceinture de sécurité
la compagnie sky est particulièrement
fière d'être la première compagnie au
monde entier qui met à votre disposition
des ceintures de sécurité à combinaison
si vous désirez quitter votre siège
pendant le vol vous trouverez aisément
votre code personnel au guichet
d'embarquement
si pendant le vol l'appareil devait
rencontrer quelques turbulences
[Musique]
vous servirions un repas léger
si la cabine devait subitement ce
dépressurisé des masques à oxygène
tomberez automatiquement des
compartiment situé au dessus de vos
têtes
mettez le masque en place respirer
normalement et fait la peur de sa vie à
votre voisin
là
dans la faible possibilité que
l'appareil s'avère incontrôlable pendant
le vol les passagers sont priés
d'adopter les positions d'atterrissage
forcé suivant
il y a douze sorties de secours dans cet
appareil deux situés sous les ailes deux
sous la queue
et 8 dans le cockpit
dans la très improbable possibilité d'un
amerrissage forcé le gilet de sauvetage
se trouve sous le siège numéro 10 c
enfiler le gilet par la tête et ajuster
le à votre taille en tirant sur les
attaches marqué 10 et 12 pour gonfler le
gilet tiré sur la cordelette
oui à marquer que jupp le gilet se
gonflera automatiquement vous assurant
confort et sécurité
[Applaudissements]
oh
arrêtés automatiquement le gonflage du
gilet il vous suffit simplement de tirer
sur la sambre
le parquet devait pas aisément
accessible autant du gilet de sauvetage
j'ai dit pour arrêter automatiquement le
gonflage jill est bon merci à la faute
et si madame foot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
syndicats français le psychologue pour
chiens de l'info est de l'intox euros à
toi de jouer ça faire plaisir à brigitte
bardot c'est de l'info tu penses mais
c'est pas moche et bardos et dorothée
oui je pense aussi à brigitte bardot et
adorons d'accord et toi sergent garcia
et je crois aussi que c'est un enfant
parce que les chiens ils ont besoin et
psychologue car ce sont tous des
psychopathes à bras
alors pour savoir la vérité
toi tu m'as dit que c'est de l'info
aussi alors pour savoir la vérité on
écoute l'expert philippe guérin à part
dont le fan club de l'odyssée boîtes
postales 95-93 215 non c'est pas ça
la plaine-saint-denis voilà et le
syndicat de psychologues pour chien
c'était de l'info bravo robin tu t'es
fait tu t'es fait planter donc bonnet
d'âne pour philippe guérin ont fait ou
[Applaudissements]
bon ben maintenant tu nous fais ton
petit commentaire on petit philippe
filou bas c'est de l'info dans l'équipe
de dorothée le savent bien que ça existe
les psychologues pour chiens puisqu'il y
à déjà des psychologues pour les enfants
haha
dafy le score 3-2 pour garcia ils
gagnent garcia way et zorro un petit
coup de fouet peut être posée euro ont
fait un ou deux euros là pour parler aux
vaillants vérité est ce que tu tiens
compte des attaques dont les programmes
sont victimes au sujet de la violence
oui bien sûr mais c'est une vieille
querelle qui était remis depuis
longtemps c'est pourquoi maintenant plus
personne n'ose rien dire
tout le monde a baissé les bras les
parents baisser les bras parce que ce
qui s'est passé violent et tout mais par
exemple un truc simple et ken le
survivant s'il était en vie d'antenne
traits du lent mais fébrile tu l'as
remis non quand même pas enlever
rapidement très rapidement levée bien
sûr on s'est trop violents voulant lever
et higuain
bon d'accord je suis comme j'en ai pas
du tout père de famille auprès de dire
ça ce soir en fait ce jugement je m'en
préoccupe pas changé c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les japonais commence à
gueuler disent qu'il ya trop de qualités
jol tu dis toujours que tu montres
effectivement enfin les séries sont
montrés des psychologues
c'est vrai toutes les visionner par des
psychologues elle voulait jamais des
noms de psychologues
maintenant pourquoi bon je pense que ça
change
mais c'est vraiment vu par des
psychodrames en vue c'est une poule de
psychologues avec un responsable la tête
et tout et tout est vérifié si un
épisode qui qui peut éventuellement
poser des problèmes vous avez pu la
faire ségolène royal ségolène royal
c'est une dame qui est craint et qui
s'appelle le ras-le-bol des bébés a peur
ou est le disais que c'était pas bien
que les enfants regardent dorothée tout
ça tu t'en souviens de sa part des
ambitions
et puis tu sais ce qui s'est passé quand
même dont on a déjà parlé un jour il y
avait une émission de dorothée du club
dorothée et via vais ariane et corbier
qui vit dans une poubelle comme ça il y
avait un livre de ségolène royal 2 l'an
je crois que c'est bien de se servir la
télévision pour répondre aux gens qui
vous ont attaqué tout c'est un méchant
c'est pas méchant on a montré son idole
en tête ça fait les petites filles
abandonnent tu crois qu'elle était
contente quand le csa a modifié les
quotas de séries japonaises
tu te souviens de ce moment là tu as
demandé aux jeunes téléspectateurs
d'écrire au csa non attendez que je
prends toujours le public pour des gens
responsables
de quel que soit leur âge je leur ai
expliqué pourquoi le mercredi après midi
qu'ils étaient devenus des heures de
grande écoute un don avec des programmes
français et européens on avait changé la
programmation des émissions et je leur
ai dit que le csa avait décidé et ses
rastas et si vous voulez leur écrire
point c'est tout je n'ai jamais c'est ce
qu'ils ont dit la réponse nous avait
reçus une lettre d'un prof et d'une
classe qui demandait qu'on supprime
justement les séries japonaises alors
pas beaucoup une lettre quand même comme
quoi c'est pour les embêter que tu les
avait appelés conseil non c'est une
surveillance de l'audiovisuel période
ces trophées ça c'est pas pour les
embêter tout mais j'ai eu plus graves
comme il ya eu la sphère des insignes
nazis sur les uniformes
c'est pas si une asie c'est ce signe est
un ski prend un signe de vie à l'envers
c'est un vrai cycle
de judo ou ne pas paraître idiot mais de
d'art martiaux ouais c'était très très
bien qu'ils existent et japonais avait
mis cela sur un uniforme dans un dessin
animé japonais ou scène avec les nazis
mais vous avez dit quand on enfin je dis
vous parce que c'était pas tout seul
bien entendu ce jeudi mais on n'avait
pas eu le temps de visionner toute la
série c'est bien que des séries qui
parce qu'ils sont pas entièrement
visionner à l'époque
et puis aussi mais ça c'est bon il a
fait un rabbin des voix si tu fais pas
de scandale
oui ça va gratuit je sais pas et des
gens qu'on dit que c'était antisémite
d'appeler une afrique g20 personnage
s'appelle robin des bois à thaon c'était
jacky berger kiseki bowditch ouais tu
avais l'auteur qui était quand même j'ai
fait également le producteur également
s'était désisté la sortie du film robin
des bois jacky était déguisé en rabbin
ses terres à bas des bois je dire c'est
de l'humour de ma fille et c'est pas
vraiment très méchant alors tu m'as
messe à jour 3 mais non parce que tu
m'as même enchaînement sur un costard de
stars que ma fille a fait sur toi ali
miaoui je crois que tu va avoir besoin
de beaucoup d'humour auprès tu traites
coster de ce fardeau
tenez vous aimez dorothée qu'un onglet
madame s'il vous plaît pour régler le
disque c 30 francs je vous ai rien mais
janet mais je sais bien c'est dorothée
camille cette technique de vente au
point ces deux ventes directes et alors
alors on donne un disque aux enfants et
les parents
la taille en santé qu'à ma chérie tu
aimes dorothée c'est pour toi
ces 33 madame ces dames en direct à
maintenant mais pas le droit de
reprendre le disque à l'emprunt dorothée
m'a permis de reprendre des listes j'ai
donné un énorme alors là c'est bien mais
c'est dorothée voie lactée mais cette
technique aux nombreux t elle n'est pas
petit et c'est ce qu'elle fait c'est
dorothée camion alors vous pouvez alors
c'est de reconnaître comme ça aux gens
on n'aimait pas à main puis à dire après
ces trente francs et ses deux
reconnaissent à dire c'est 30 francs on
va merci hein c'est pour moi vous me le
donner oui c'est une vente directe c'est
dorothée camille cette vente au point
pour se faire des couilles en or vous
êtes obligé où l'avait touché madame
j'ai pas de monnaie je vous en donne 3g
pas de monnaie alors je vous donne un
club dorothée je veux te plonger un
pin's j'ai un vibromasseur
qu'est ce que je vais le stérilet
dorothée qui vient de sortir vous voulez
quoi qu'est ce que vous voulez aller
jouer sur l'autoroute les enfants à lire
dorothée n'aime pas les enfants alors
foutez lui la paix à dorothée un tiens
c'est pour vous voilà non c'est 30
francs madame pouvait m'arriver s'il
vous plaît j'ai pas loin de reprendre
madame dorothée m'interdit de reprendre
les disques que je donne aux enfants
c'est pas bon pour son image
ces deux retraités a mis cette technique
au point qu'à ma chérie il faut faire
comme amélie vous êtes les chante avec
vos enfants et mon chéri c'est toi toi
j'ai pas mal de reprendre mon poème
régler s'il vous plaît mais
plaignez-vous à dorothée si vous n'êtes
pas contente
regardez-vous les ailes et la faire
pleurer mais j'allais rendre entre
enfants malheureux
moi je pense que ce principe mais c'est
dorothée qui a mis ses principaux
partenaires de voter je trouve que c'est
débile en plus sert pas la colonne
n'empêche que ça rapporte du pognon et
c'est ça le principal elle est à
déplorer
c'est moi qui tu lofteuse hop je
l'espérais de ma poche
m
[Applaudissements]
alors non je vais te dire la vérité mais
de dire la vérité je pensais à la suite
de cette séquence te demander de venir
s'excuser mais je pense que la réaction
de rock était quand même beaucoup plus
drôle c'est maintenant j'ai un début
d'érection matin bravo toi t'es dit je
me mouille pas dans les sujets je crois
que dorothée eu la bonne réaction
c'est vrai on applaudit dorothée
c'est bon tu connais c'est bien fait ça
va la même édition
vous avez dit elle a des couilles bon et
bien voilà c'est non mais ça va
maintenant tu ça va il est plus mou
victoire non je suis très mouillé ça se
voit pas on
pas mal fini sa geôle au label qui est
le lot alors bon an mal an on arrive à
la question que se posent tous les
journalistes et je vous parle je parle
pour l'instant sur la gueule ce qu'on
pourra voir à ce 284 tu rêvais d'avoir
des jumeaux ne rêverait pas d'avoir des
je disais je rêve d'avoir des jumeaux
si j'envoie des enfants tant que ça des
jumeaux ces deux d'un coup c'est plus
vite 188 tu disais ne pas vouloir
d'enfant parce que j'étais trop occupé
pour bien s'en occuper
le jour où tu en auras tu quitteras tout
dire ou est ce que c'est parce que tu ne
veux pas tout quitter que tu n'en fais
pas bête comme question
non c'est ça se fait pas comme ça
ouais des enfants non ce serait laxiste
avec eux non j'étais j'ai une indication
très sévère je serai sévère tu pense
qu'il faut les tenir les gosses alors
oui parce que sinon tu as vu ce que ça
donne jetez plus une façon l'inde était
injuste un gpu un seau d'eau on n'était
même pas collégiens
est ce que est ce que serait ce que les
gosses
est ce que tes gosses si un jour tu as
des enfants est-ce qu'ils auront le
droit de regarder dorothée sais pas si
je serai encore là ouais mais à ton
habitude et laisserait regarder des
chiffres
bon si tu rencontré l'homme de ta vie tu
qui traite ou une supposition
non tu qu'il serait pas tenable si bien
devient c'est honnête de le dire tu
pourrais le rencontrer ou ce mec-là
parce que quand tu travailles beaucoup
et que le reste du temps tu es chez toi
ou chez ta mère tu penses que tu vas pas
dans les boîtes qui pourrait le
rencontrer ou l'homme de ta vie ah oui
quand on raconte là mais j'espère encore
au contraire la tapa je t'ai dit que je
n'y ai point déjà rencontrées à aa
on va envoyer des paparazzi devant chez
toi tu veux pas vieillir seul ça te
ferait peur de vieillir salle ne serait
pas peur tellement loin est ce que tu es
oui est ce que tu as des chéquiers
sensuellement troublé par une femme non
jamais jamais une émotion comme ça quand
tu étais chez les soeurs soit le mans
soeur et ses copines d'école n'ont
jamais bon écoute on va arrêter alors on
va parler de la contraception mais chez
les pigeons jaiku genre ouais c'est
mieux qu'est-ce qui rivalise avec les
incontournables crottes de chien les
inévitables fientes de pigeons les
dégâts occasionnés par ces volatiles
décoratif mais envahissant coûte à la
collectivité des sommes à ce jour
pratiquement 1 chiffrable mais sûrement
très élevé quelles solutions pour
diminuer le nombre de pigeons en voici
une
mais elles ne recueillent pas le soutien
enthousiaste des associations de défense
des animaux restent donc intervenir à la
source par la contraception
le docteur miracle est un laboratoire
pharmaceutique vétérinaire qui a mis au
point la pilule pour les pigeons notre
produit s'appelle horny stérile il est à
base de progestérone comme la plupart
des pilules féminine dans l'hystérie il
se présente d'une forme de grains de
maïs enrobé de progestérone sur lequel
une laque de fixateur donc pour éviter
lors des intempéries et le police ed
grable ce produit se donnent tous les
jours mais s'il y en a dix ruptures le
week-end par exemple on peut donner la
dose double le vendredi et le lundi
en france cette pilule est distribué
dans une trentaine de villes par les
services municipaux
mais à paris vu le trop grand nombre de
pigeons les mairies ne pourrait pas
assumer cette tâche quotidienne
ce sont donc des bénévoles qui s'en
charge
aujourd'hui l'association comporte à peu
près minimum
nous sommes une centaine de personnes
qui ont décidé des sirènes en hystérie
la pêche la prolifération des pigeons et
ça nous coûte environ entre 250 euros à
300 euros par mois
cook et thomson j'ai comme les gens qui
a beaucoup de monde est à bouger et
étouffer un bon alors reste à savoir
c'est tous les parisiens sont d'accord
pour que la contraception fasse diminuer
le nombre de ses ornements dans la
capitale les pigeons ces cinq vols de
paris comme moi pas de problème
papineau pigeonne et pas qu'un peu de
prison alors à votre santé hôpitaux
tony chan d'ailleurs en parlant de
michou il y avait 1
un travesti szczesny chauvet en sosie la
semaine derrière ce ne pas choquer non
pas du tout bon j'avais peur un peu que
ça veut dire mais coûte finalement
témoins beagle que ce qu'on croit on
peut croire ça donc mesdames messieurs
la pilule pour les pigeons de paris s de
l'info est de l'intox
pendant que vous réfléchissez pendant
que je euros et garcia réfléchisse corti
qu'est ce qu'on regarde
ouais
le groupe allemand
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur b
ce soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
y at il eu
les pigeons du pari s
os de l'intox sergent garcia c'est à toi
de jouer
ben ouais j'y crois que que c'est de
l'info parce que je crois qu'il faut
empêcher le tir aux pigeons à l'horizon
dur de rivaliser
c'est quoi de la sortie je n'ai je
dirais que c'est de l'info également
également de l'info soit dorothée je
sais qu'on veut les éliminer mais au
coût de la pilule je ne sais pas bon bah
écoutes je crois que le plus simple
c'est d'écouter experts philippe gas on
a fait la totale en intox la semaine
dernière on faisait la totale on a fait
ce soir et on s'est planté c'était de
l'info bonnet d'âne dont philippe currat
megan bonnet d'âne mon fils ou t'es pas
vexé il est tout triste tu joues non
mais ça va ça ira mieux la semaine
prochaine je l'espère bon c'était très
dur ce soir
oui qu'un petit commentaire oui thierry
m'a fait moi ton des commentaires mon
bébé c'était de l'info et c'est pour
cela qu'on dit aux enfants depuis des
années de ne pas manger les petites
graines qui traînent par terre parce que
si vous voulez manger les petites
graines qui traînent par terre vous
risquez d'avoir les yeux [ __ ] comme
dans les dessins animés de dorothée y en
a qui va se loger
alors va plus moi je dis que le score
maintenance et 4,3 pour le sergent qui
est gagné
[Applaudissements]
je prends ton petit téléviseur tu
regardes les cadeaux philips qui
défilent et tu me dis celui que tu veux
[Musique]
où est le magnétoscope le magnétoscope
pal secam trois têtes vidéo avec touches
spéciales attention pour faciliter
l'installation
bravo cerveau versée
aujourd'hui comme je sais que tu as
toutes les études dans une institution
et je veux me fait marrer parce que
c'est à bourg-la-reine et que l'autre
ali leïla tente à côté de choisy-le-roi
l'hawaiien déjà vu avant il aurait dit
bourg-la-reine pas maintenant un état
plus elle peut plus vieux tu l'a calmé
tu là je sèche mois ils sèchent
doucement aux travailleurs ce qu'on fait
si tu as l'habitude de se confesser et
nanterre
alors tu me suis bien avec moi doté mais
sur l'eau
[Musique]
c'est vrai que tu procèdes des actions
charitables dans les hôpitaux
oui tu le dit pas trop au centre parce
que ça c'est pas c'est pas à crier sur
les toits c'est ma vie à moi et je le
fais comme ça ça tu fais vraiment oui
c'est vrai que tu est la marraine d'un
petit garçon indien on parle pas
beaucoup nombreuses banon n'a pas
forcément besoin de crier sont sur les
toits tout ce qu on se complaît faire
une mais non si tu veux c'est une chose
que je fais parce que j'ai envie de le
faire et puis c'est tout n'est jamais
pas savoir most pas à reprendre son nom
mais jour serait ce pas parce que tu
crois en dieu oui du prisme tous les
jours ça se traduit comme hors du coup
et c'est une vraie prière où s'ouvrira
toi qui est aussi ma vie mes prières
dans toutes les questions ont été posées
ce soir quelle est celle qui t'a le plus
embêté c'est que tu vas me poser
maintenant alors je suis posé la
question comment ça se fait maintenant
répondre moi pour la dernière fois
comment ça se fait que tu n'es pas je ne
sois pas marié tu n'es pas d'enfant que
tu sois tout seul c'est comment c'est
possible
ce sont des choses qui arrivent mais je
ne suis pas forcément tout seul c'est en
tout seul que ça on a vu quelqu'un
répond non écrite
donc c'est ça qui m'embête c'est quand
on parle de ça et je peux avoir ma vie à
moi comme un sans forcément mentir ou
outré chez y a que vous qui posez ces
questions des enfants les pousse pas je
crois que tu es sincère je trouve
compliqué très cher
[Musique]
oh
des corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux